hello friends i'm alan and welcome to my
channel where today i'm going to be
reacting to black myth
wukong i wasn't sure if i wanted to do
this one because i feel like i've done
so much
reaction content lately which i don't
love but it's really just because it was
dc fandom and gamescom and e3 felt like
it lasted like several months
just the way this year is means we've
been getting a lot of trailers and weird
times
but people are still asking me to do it
despite it being revealed about a week
ago
um so i feel like it must be pretty cool
and i also saw there's literally 13
minutes of gameplay so it's pretty
meaty so uh i'm watching this
on ign's channel let's do it
i think the only thing that i know right
now excuse this puppy ad
is that this game is made by a chinese
developer i believe
and that it's made on journey to the
west
which i am a little bit familiar with uh
so it should be super cool
okay let's go
what's so cool
looks beautiful
[Music]
well this gives me dark souls vibe so
maybe that's just because of the bell
huh
it is a really cool piece of mythology
to see that take on it
okay
[Applause]
gameplay footage decor directly from a
pre-alpha game build work in progress
got it okay roger that
that's a lot of detail
very pretty damn the puddles
you know i've been to a lot of game
studios and i don't know maybe 50 that
i've made like mini docs and interview
dev teams
every single one has always said
lighting is
uh they say the most expensive thing in
a game um
lighting is difficult oh i didn't expect
that
all right
uh but yeah because of that i feel like
i always pay a lot of attention to
lighting and i
feel like i didn't see the electricity
reflecting
in the water there which is like you
know extremely difficult
but uh the lighting in this is gorgeous
all right some jedi [ __ ]
wonderful
he did actually burn some of them away
very cool
what happened there was it was a parry
oh that's so cool
i wonder why they're not attacking is
that for like the purposes of this video
but i feel like it's not
or or is it because that's the way the
gameplay is you just can't play very
offensive
okay certainly got more offensive
give you that weapon
i want a fire stick
dude this looks so rad
i mean it's clipping through the the
plant there but who cares
it's video games
something about that animation was very
cool
the clothing physics looks solid there
obviously this is the cut scene but
still
[Music]
cute little guy
[Music]
curious how open world this is
it looked like there were branching
parts earlier um
but it could be pretty linear which for
the record i don't mind don't mind a
linear game
enslaved also uh odyssey to the west
very linear great game
shout out to ninja theory
what's happening here what's all this
what's all this
i like that they don't seem to be
waiting to attack
which is the thing that like bothers me
in a lot of games
damn those transitions are
so cool
this is very good i'm very glad i'm
watching this
[Music]
big wolf not quite
not that far off looks like a ballerina
that's fable reference
i mean the lighting on that photo looks
stunning i should make sure i'm playing
with some 1080.
oh yeah good stuff good stuff
cool
i love the way this is animated
did it leave permanent damage on the
roof i pay attention to like such minor
details that i know most gamers don't
care about but i'm like what happened
all right
yeah do you love a game where you can
call in uh
recruits are they dead people the people
you killed
yeah i really wanted to see this as soon
as you picked it up
give me fire stick
[Music]
you know this fight is way harder than
they're making it look right
gotta acknowledge that
[Music]
who you who you throwing down at but
there's nobody even over there
oh you just burnt his butthole crisp
oh
that was rad
the mythology of it is really neat
didn't expect that [ __ ]
stunning it's bloody beautiful
i did wonder if there was going to be
climbing mechanics and i guess that
little shot confirmed it
so definitely obviously sakura vibes
from sub vibes in general
but absolutely unique enough that this
doesn't look like a dark souls clone
um which a lot of games that are similar
to anything in that series
or anything from that studio get plagued
with
[Music]
it's beautiful combat looks brad
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what oh it's goku
[Music]
[Applause]
didn't expect that this looks like 99
[Music]
nights
like does it turn into dynasty warriors
damn man very cool i am on board
100 a game of the year
[Music]
left
[Music]
cool as hell man
damn it's funny for someone to get very
upset about this
say goku copied it yes for anyone who
didn't know this comment is correct
goku is inspired off of the journey to
the west as a chinese i want to give you
more information about this game there
are only 30 people in this team right
now they have enough funding and they
have strong faith to complete the game
however they still need more talent to
join the team and face the heavy
workloads so recruiting is the main
purpose of releasing this trailer that's
interesting
okay so i just wanted to find out a
little bit more about the studio before
we uh
wrap this one up this is from game rant
this is black myth wukong developer
responds to trailer popularity after its
13-minute gameplay trailer exploded in
popularity
developer responds and provides an
update on the game responding to the
newfound support on the website weibo
and translated by reset era member
nightingale
game science founder feng ji provided an
overview of the 13 minute gameplay
trailer
so yeah the original intent of the
footage was actually less about trying
to impress people with the game and more
about attracting potential employees to
work at the studio
very cool he goes on to ask that fans
forget about the trailer as it doesn't
represent the team's best work
are you [ __ ] me dude what
most of the post is then used to
highlight things that are wrong in the
gameplay footage including a moment
where the frame rate drops in the fight
between the main character wukong
and a crowd of enemies huh water in the
footage also has no physical properties
the soundtrack doesn't quite sync up
interesting
i respect it well i guess that's worth
noting game science studio now intends
to go dark to continue working on black
myth wukong if that youtube comment was
right there are only 30 people on the
scene this game is going to be years out
we're not going to see this game for
literally years
um so interesting choice to release the
trailer is a recruiting tool
i respect it i would work on it although
the game appears to be a ways off
there's still no official word if
blackmail
wukong is even going to be released
outside of china
i feel like that's probably pretty
likely now confirmed a pc release
and all mainstream host platforms so
yeah probably next gen consoles but
uh it's probably super far away
absolutely
um awesome and that's coming off of a
week of me hearing that this trailer was
the best thing ever so it wasn't
overhyped for me at all
sign me up i'm ready sub me in chief